- My name is Abhijit Bose.
I head the Enterprise AI/ML
Platforms and Engineering
for Capital One.
We have a few Capital
One folks here as well.
We are responsible for strategy
development and execution
of our enterprise AI/ML infrastructure,
which powers most of the AI/ML
applications at the company.
Here is a quick look at the agenda.
I will start with a few
slides on AI at Capital One.
It's actually a 10-year journey for us.
It's been, you know, a
series of innovations
we have done over the years,
I would say transformations,
that led to this moment,
you know, where we are
at the frontier of AI.
And then core to our strategy,
there are two things.
The first one is the custom AI.
A lot of folks, a lot of
companies are using AI.
But core to our strategy is
how do we build custom AI
that run in tune with our infrastructure,
that run using our own customized models.
And then the second part of our
strategy is the AI platform.
And in this presentation,
I'll focus more on the AI platform.
There is another big
conference going on this week,
which is NeurIPS.
If you follow NeurIPS,
you can follow some of
the Capital One talks
by my colleagues there.
There you will find out more
about our customized model
and that custom AI strategy.
But in this talk,
it'll be more about the
platform and infrastructure.
I will also go over a
particular case study
that's, I think, on a
lot of people's mind.
How do we deploy agentic coding tools?
But the way we are deploying it is
actually using our own
platform to deploy that
with the right set of guardrails,
with the right set of, you know, gateway,
that actually makes it
much more well-managed
and scalable throughout the company.
And, of course, you know,
none of this would be possible
without having great talent.
I'm really fortunate
to have such wonderful,
extremely exceptional, you
know, talent at the company.
So I'm gonna focus on a
couple of things we are doing
to really be at the forefront of AI
so that we build a brand name
so that we can attract the
best talent in the world
to work with us.
But first I want to share
some quick context about Capital One.
We are a 30-year-old,
founder-led Fortune 100 company.
The founder-led is really, you
know, kind of important for,
for me, having come from Facebook.
Our founder, Rich Fairbank,
works very actively hands-on
with us on our AI strategy.
And that actually has
made my life much easier.
And, you know, a lot of other
AI leaders at the company,
we are just fortunate to
have such a, you know,
forward-leaning and very innovative CEO
at the helm of the company.
We are also the nation's
largest direct bank.
And along the way,
we have been recognized as one
of the best places to work.
But I will focus on, I'll just
draw your attention to two.
In the last three years,
we have been number one in
talent in the Evident AI index,
that actually takes in, I
think, 50 or 60 global banks
and then rates them on their
AI maturity, you know, talent,
how responsible they have been
in deploying AI at the company, et cetera.
And then the second one is that,
this just came out recently,
we are now top 10 companies in the world
along with Google, Microsoft,
you know, Nvidia, Samsung,
in terms of the generative
and agentic AI patents.
You know, all of this is to say
that just to highlight
the focus on innovation
and the relentless focus on developing
and attracting talent at the company.
So, you know, it's not a surprise
that we are at this moment
of AI transforming so
many, you know, businesses,
so much of society.
But our history as a technology innovator
actually positions us really well.
Before I go to the next slide,
but the foundations of
our company is build,
are built on our heritage of
data-driven decision making,
modern-tech stack.
We have our in-house data
science and engineering talent.
We are all in the cloud.
I joined the company in late 2020,
and that was the year we got
out of our last data center.
I still remember we celebrated that.
We have been in, you know,
AWS primarily since then.
We have done a lot of work
in transforming our data
ecosystem at the company.
And as you know, your data advantage
is really your AI advantage these days.
And then we have a
history, very rich history.
We have a DNA of enterprise platforms.
We don't do bespoke application
development at the company.
From data to AI to cloud,
wherever we see a common pattern,
we build platforms that
everybody in the company uses.
And AI is no exception to that.
And then, of course, you know,
we are exceptional at risk management.
But this does not happen overnight.
This takes, you know, many years.
As our senior leaders say, you
know, it's a lonely journey
with a lot of hard work.
And for us, it started
almost 10 years ago.
And I'm not gonna go
through the timelines,
but you can see those
like from open source
to declaring we were all in the cloud,
to getting out of our
last data center in 2020,
launching Capital One software,
where we took some of the capabilities.
We were building in-house for ourselves.
We saw an opportunity to
actually take those to the market
for other businesses, other companies.
And that actually brought a
very different perspective
to our software engineers
and product managers,
because now we are not just the customer,
but we are more service providers.
So things like multi-tenancy
became very important
for all of us.
Even in the AI platform,
I remember the first kind of the impetus
for multi-tenancy started, you know,
when Capital One software
started working with us,
and we realized that
not all of our platforms
and capabilities were
built for multi-tenancy.
And now every capability that we build,
it has to be multi-tenant
because someday we might
actually externalize that service
to other customers.
In late 2024, we started
kind of the groundwork
for building our first agentic
application at the company.
And then in January of this year,
we launched our first customer-facing,
multi-agentic application
called Chat Concierge.
I'm gonna briefly talk about that.
And that again was a
pivotal moment for us.
You know, this is the first time
a bank really exposed
a multi-agentic system
in front of live customers
live in the market.
We learned a ton from that.
And we are, and as I'll
show you, we learned,
that we took all the lessons learned,
and then we kind of like
reformulated our platform plans.
And now we are all in agents
and how we scale agents at the company.
We are also using AI
extensively at the company
for all kinds of applications.
Here are some examples.
I already talked about the
multi-agentic AI workflow
called Chat Concierge.
We also use AI for real-time
fraud detection and mitigation.
Many of you are familiar with
Transformer architecture.
We use Transformers these days
to personalize user experiences
on our mobile and webpages.
If you use our Capital
One Shopping plugin,
it uses AI to find the right
offer for you from the right,
you know, merchant as you are checking in,
checking out, you know, your SKU.
And then if you use our
Capital One Auto Navigator app,
it uses image recognition
to find you the right card
that you are looking for.
Again, those are, by AI,
I mean not generative AI.
A lot of these are, you know, neural nets.
But, you know, more and more
we are also using LLM-driven
and agentic AI systems.
Now, let's talk about
where we are going with AI
at the enterprise.
Now, we all realize that AI
is not just a new technology.
It is going to fundamentally
change our business,
fundamentally change our processes
that we use at the company.
Now, when it comes to
scaling AI at any large,
you know, regulated industry like ours,
I think all of us have
to deal with two things.
One is the need for speed.
You know, every other day,
there is a new something happening,
you know, new model coming up,
or some inferencing, you know,
algorithm optimization comes up.
Lot of work is happening
in agentic coding tools.
We are seeing real benefits.
So there is a lot of pressure on all of us
to actually come bring
these tools into the company
and deploy them.
But we also have to make sure
that all these tools are well-managed.
You know, we have zero tolerance
for cyber or risk failures
and we have an exceptionally
high bar on those.
So how do you build at the frontier of AI
at the speed of well-managed?
That is the core problem
statement, I think, for all of us.
Those who work in, you
know, large companies
and regulated industries,
we have to deal with.
Now, before I go to the next page,
I want to define the
speed of well-managed,
because that's also something we learned.
You know, it's not the
speed that we were used to
maybe even three years ago.
With AI, we also have
to lift our risk, cyber,
you know, governance, all of
the controls that we deploy,
all of the audit functions in the company.
So the speed here is also increasing.
It's not just, you
know, AI is moving fast,
but my processes are still slow.
That's not gonna work.
So how do we lift all boats?
That's the core, you know,
of the problem statement.
Now, to us,
to build that company
that innovates at the speed of AI,
but also at the speed of well-managed,
it comes down to this building blocks,
proprietary data, cloud and serverless,
GPUs or, you know, compute infrastructure,
modern-tech stack, enterprise platforms,
I'll mention about that,
in-house talent, risk, governance,
and then the last one
is model customization.
It's not just using the, you know,
third-party frontier models
that are available at an API.
But the companies that are gonna be
at the forefront of this,
they will leverage their own
data to build LLMs from scratch
and customized for various, you know,
specialized tasks at the company.
And they need to have the
infrastructure and talent
to then deploy them at scale,
at the, you know, same
level of sophistication
as some of the frontier model
companies have been doing.
Now, as I said, you know, we
set out to do all of those
through two things, you
know, customized models,
and now I'm gonna come
to the enterprise AI platform part of it.
Now, we have been
building this AI platform
for last four years, and
we have learned a lot.
We have redesigned a few
things over the years.
But couple of basic principles
have stayed the same.
For example, for the best AWS services,
we take them, we build
on the shoulders of them.
So, for example, EKS, ECS,
SageMaker, Bedrock, OpenSearch,
you know, EFS, S3,
FSX for last year, for high
performance file system
for GPU cluster.
We have taken them,
but we have also built
a lot of other capabilities on our own.
And then we have also incorporated
a lot of open source
projects into our platform.
So this particular combination
of AWS services, open source,
and our custom proprietary capabilities
that actually has helped us
to be at the forefront of AI.
And we are at a stage now
where we can mix third party
and first party capabilities
almost interchangeably
into our stack to be,
you know, very quick and fast
in deploying a lot of capabilities
at the company at scale.
If there is one kind of like, you know,
nugget of information I can give you is
that being able to design a control plane,
being able to design a stack
where you can bring in these three things
easily in a well-managed way,
that is something, you
know, people should take on
because it's not just about depending
on a vendor for everything.
It's not about building
everything on your own.
Then you will miss out on
a lot of the innovation.
And then it's also not,
open source is not enough in many cases.
So in the next few slides, I'm
gonna talk about two things.
Two parts of the platform.
One is the model training or
our training infrastructure,
how we build using,
again, three different,
you know, pieces of capabilities.
And then very importantly,
the inferencing capabilities.
So if you think of like
the modern GenAI stack,
you have to have
a really well-designed
training infrastructure,
and you need to have very well-designed,
high-performance inference infrastructure.
Of course, traditional, you
know, core ML had that too,
model training and model inference.
But in case of LMS and generative
AI, it is really complex,
much more complex than what
we have dealt in the past
for core machine learning.
So I'm gonna talk about our HPC clusters.
It's been about, I would
say, maybe two years.
And we learned a lot.
You know, at the basic level,
it's basically compute,
network, and storage.
And you could say, how difficult is it?
Like you get your compute from AWS.
You get your storage.
You know, you get your network
like EFA, storage like FSX.
But we find that you need to build
a lot of additional
capabilities on top of that
to be really at the tipping,
the kind of like at the bleeding age
of, you know, building very large models
that, you know, where
nodes fail all the time,
you don't want to waste these,
you know, GPU resources,
which are very expensive.
And you also have to invest
in your training pipelines,
you know, so that those, you
know, are also very efficient.
So this is what we did.
We took the infrastructure,
a lot of it from AWS Native,
you know, capabilities.
That's the left hand side of the slide.
Things like high-speed networking,
scheduling and queuing,
high performance file system,
GPU nodes recovery, et cetera.
The software stack, the heart
of the training pipeline,
and these are training
pipelines that need to run,
you know, jobs across many
GPUs, hundreds of GPUs,
or sometimes thousands of
GPUs in a distributed way.
That was mostly open source
and our own custom pipelines,
and we tuned that to the hardware.
And then the third one,
the thing on the right, user experience,
a lot of that, we had to
build all by ourselves.
So this is a perfect
example of you can build,
you know, world-class infrastructure
with combination of AWS open
source and your own stack.
And all of this has been built
by our own in-house AI
researchers and engineering team.
But we didn't do this, you know, in a day.
It was really a learning
experience for us.
We did it in three phases.
In the first phase,
we got a lot of the
infrastructure procured
and provisioned by AWS.
In phase two, we focused
on our training pipeline
and really building
that in-house knowledge of
how could the kernels work.
You know, even even debugging GPU,
like training code that
runs on GPU is very complex.
So we had to build a lot
of that expertise in-house.
And then in phase three,
we started to become more
and more sophisticated.
We focused on minimizing downtime.
How quickly can you
checkpoint restart a job,
you know, that has filled on one GPU.
And so you can think of this as a journey
that you have to go through.
And it took us probably about a,
you know, year or so to get really,
you know, to the point where we are now.
And this is kind of the
training infrastructure
that looks today.
You know, I will tell
you a few things that,
at the top you see the
diversity of the users
we support on this training
infrastructure today.
And this is not just one cluster
that we maintain a few different clusters,
you know, for custom build,
for certain kind of jobs
like RL, you know, versus
like post-training RL,
versus like pre-training
or specialized transformer
for certain applications.
But there are whole range of users
with varying knowledge of infrastructure,
but they don't have to deal
with much of the complexity
of a GPU cluster today.
Thanks to a lot of the, you know,
abstractions we have built
in how you submit a job,
how you debug, et cetera.
It's also built for multi-tenancy.
We can stand up a cluster
for certain application,
certain division within the company
where there may be strict
data, you know, restrictions.
And again, you know,
as I mentioned earlier,
multi-tenancy is kind of in our DNA now
after, you know, Capital One software.
Yeah, and then at the bottom-most layer,
you know, we have the data layer
where we can bring in data from Snowflake.
We have a pretty large
Snowflake footprint.
We have S3. We have other data lake.
And then of course a lot of
the data need to come into FSX
to feed the GPUs.
I'm gonna talk about, next, our
model hosting and inference.
And this is something, you know,
again, a lot of you have realized this,
is that training cost
is kind of like fixed
or, you know, once you
have trained the model,
you know, you have incurred
a certain kind of cost,
but your inference cost is just starting
at that point, right?
And if you are not careful
with your inference platform,
that itself can be a huge expense.
You know, you are not gonna
get the kind of the economics
of these token or per query right.
And as a result,
you know, what worked for
100 users as a prototype,
you will find that that doesn't work
when you have to support
100 million customers
with that GenAI applications.
And when you hear, you know, like,
"Oh, a lot of GenAI applications are dying
at the POC level,"
one of the reasons it dies, you know,
is that people haven't thought through
how to really develop the infrastructure
and how to really create
the cost structure
to scale it to millions
and millions of customers,
you know, millions of tokens
per minute, for example.
So we took this very seriously.
You know, in our first iteration,
we put together a system that worked.
It supported a smaller number
of, you know, users internally
for an internal application.
But for us it was existential
that we have to get really world-class
in our inference platform capability.
So there are three things here.
First is the cost per token
or cost per query at scale,
unit economics,
then the user experience,
latency and throughput.
You know, when we first
deployed the Chat Concierge,
and I'll get to that
in a couple of slides,
Chat Concierge, we had,
because it's multiple
agents, multiple LLM calls,
I remember we were getting
something around 40 seconds
from the point you ping the,
you know, you put your query
and then the system will come back
and, you know, answer,
give you the answer back in 40 seconds.
Now it's about one second.
So that did not happen,
you know, without a lot
of the optimizations
in our inference stack, on
our model customization stack.
This is why, you know, this,
it's not just about AI,
but it's custom AI that
you have to figure out
what works for your own enterprise.
That's where the leverage is.
And that's where I think
things are heading.
And, of course, reliability.
If you're gonna maintain
a large fleet of GPUs
for inference, you know,
uptime dependencies
and how much you can pack within each GPU,
how many inference calls,
those things start to matter.
Now, we faced a dilemma.
And I think it's very common
for a lot of companies
who are experimenting or deploying GenAI,
and I'm sure some of you
are familiar with this,
that, should I go to a
managed, you know, provider,
I get an API,
I get, you know, a Llama,
or, you know, Claude,
or, you know, a lot of
different models behind an API,
and I get started right away?
So I have huge velocity, you know?
And I pay by tokens, right?
And so if my usage pattern
is variable, it makes sense.
You can pay by usage.
And then of course,
you'll be trading off on,
you know, data privacy.
You have to audit them.
You have to make sure
that they are not using
your data for training
or there is, you know,
leakage going on somewhere,
you know, exposing user-level
information outside.
And then even when you
go to a managed provider,
depending on your scale,
as you are going from
like 30 users dock footing
to 1,000 users to 1 million
to 10 million to 100 million,
at some point you'll find that,
"Okay, this economics probably
does not work for me anymore
because I'm paying so much, you know,
for my tokens all the time."
So then the other side of
that is the self-hosted option
where you have to have
now your own DevOps team,
your own AI engineers.
You know, you have to
get GPUs provisioned.
There is a fixed cost to all of that.
And the answer for us was that, you know,
like many other choices in
life, it's actually both.
So we have been able to
design a control plane
where we actually host a
third-party, you know, platform
for certain types of use cases.
And then we also host our own
platform inference platform
where we can really optimize end to end
like our own custom models,
our own inference stack,
our own hardware provision,
to really optimize the
latency, throughput, and cost.
And these are some
examples of optimizations
that we have done
in our in-house self-hosted
inference platform.
I talked about model-level optimizations.
But we have also done
a lot of infrastructure
stack optimization,
which is basically how do
you maximize the GPU usage
by bin packing, you know,
by putting multiple
tenants on the same GPU,
but then you have to worry
about, you know, data separation,
query separation, and all of that.
It's, you know, you have
to build those systems.
But we have been able to get
orders of magnitude lower
from where we started,
you know, about a year ago
on this optimization
work to now where we are,
to the point that we
feel that we will reach
a level that's comparable to
any other provider outside.
And in fact, that's our benchmark.
Like if we can get as
competitive as any other,
like OpenAI, Anthropic, you know, GCP,
or, you know, Bedrock,
we need to be in the same league there.
Now I'm gonna talk a little
bit about Chat Concierge.
So I talked about the LLM
training, LLM inferencing.
You know, as we are building those things,
there are also agents story happening
in the broader GenAI ecosystem.
So in 2024, we started working on,
is our first kind of use
case, it's for consumers.
When you go look for a car,
a lot of dealerships offer you a chatbot
and you can interact with the chatbot.
You can say, "I'm looking for
a, you know, whatever car,
you know, this color,
this model, you know?
Do you have it in your inventory?"
So we have a very, you know,
well-established auto business,
a very forward-thinking auto business.
It's not the traditional auto lending.
We also work with a lot of dealers
to build a lot of the dealer
backend software platforms
that go into lending,
maintaining the dealer websites,
you know, a lot of the
capabilities that dealer need
to interact with customers.
So one of the ideas was
that can we build a chat bot
on top of our AI platform
that will be hosted on our platform,
but there'll be a little chat
window on dealer websites.
And then prospective customers
will be interacting with it.
But then our agentic framework,
on the Capital One side,
will actually do the actual conversation.
So that's the product.
It's called Chat Concierge.
Now, to build a product,
we, you know, did a few
iterations initially.
But then we landed on a
multi-agentic framework called MACAW
to build this,
and I'll show you a little
slide on MACAW next.
But then we also had
to build a lot of the,
you know, a lot of the
kind of vertical stack
to support this agentic application.
For example, we used TensorRT,
you know, for LLM hosting for that.
We used Llama and then, you
know, fine tune Llama models
for the task.
We had to build some custom guardrails.
Chat Concierge today is
on many dealer websites.
And we have very aggressive ramp-up plans
to many hundreds and thousands of dealers.
If you get a chance, you
can play with it on the web.
But this particular agentic framework
turned out to be a very
general-purpose framework
where we start with an understanding agent
that starts interacting with the customer
to understand the intent.
So, for example, if I say
I'm looking for a blue BMW,
to figure out that I'm
looking for a car called BMW
with color blue,
that's the understanding agent.
Then it passes off that
information to a planner agent,
which does some planning.
And then that planner agent hands it off
to an evaluator agent that
has access to a sandbox
with a bunch of APIs,
with some synthetic data to
do a simulation essentially,
to figure out, "Is my answer
or reply gonna be correct?"
And then once, you know, it's satisfied,
it hands it off to the explainer agent,
which then re, kind of like,
frames, you know, the code
and the output of the evaluator
agent in human language
so that the customer, you know,
for the customer,
it's a natural-language-conversation-based
interaction.
And this is multi-turn, multi-pass.
So anytime, you know, for
example, planner agent can go back
to the understanding agent,
basically asking for more
information for the customer
so that it can plan, you know, better.
And of course we supply
it with memory, knowledge,
tools and APIs.
You know, for example,
these tools would be calling
dealer inventory in real time
or scheduling, you know, API
so that the dealer can actually,
the customer can set up a
time to come to the dealership
to test drive a car.
Even to do the tool calling.
you know, we had to do a bunch of work
to make sure the LLM is
calling the right tool
in the evaluator agent part of it.
Now, it turned out that this
particular goal-oriented,
you know, planning and
evaluation and explainer is
actually very general-purpose
agentic framework.
So now we are in the
process of generalizing it
and deploying it for many
use cases at the company.
Now, the first version of
Chat Concierge was more of a,
you know, custom built.
We had a very limited time window.
And we didn't feel like we have
to build a whole ecosystem.
We were not sure what
the outcome would be.
It was more of an, you
know, exploratory work.
Once we validated the idea,
and once we started seeing,
you know, good usage of it
and ramping up, you know,
in dealerships across the country,
then we started to put
together a plan for,
how do we now generalize it?
How do we now build an agentic ecosystem
and agentic platform,
again, sitting on top of our
AI platform core capabilities
so that we can really scale decisions
everywhere in the company.
That took us in the path,
you know, that you see here.
The last two ones, the GenAI core services
and GenAI foundation services
were already kind of in place
because of where AI work, like GenAI work.
But a lot of the agent
orchestrator, agent runtime,
you know, agent development
kit, agent marketplace,
application lifecycle
management, part of it,
those are new things that
we are continuing to build
and we have, you know, work to do here.
But once we have that
infrastructure in place,
anybody in the company
would be able to create
their own agent,
you know, put it on our platform,
and, from that point on,
using our SDK agent development kit.
And then at that point,
the platform will manage that
agent on behalf of the user.
And to us, again, it goes back
to the enterprise platform idea
that we don't want these
things to, you know,
to be bespoke capabilities
across the company.
We want everybody to use the platform
and scale agentic AI for
all kinds of applications.
So with that, I'm gonna
talk about a case study
on agentic coding tools.
I think everywhere everyone
in this room has heard
about like Cursor, Windsurf, Claude Code,
you know, Antigravity,
and so on, so forth.
The example that I'm gonna show you,
it'll talk about Claude Code,
but it's actually a general blueprint.
And at Capital One, we
have been deploying,
you know, a lot of these tools
and we are experimenting early days.
You know, we are learning a lot
how to really embed these tools
into our software development life cycle.
But all the things that
I talked about being,
you know, enterprise
platforms, data maturity,
our focus on, you know, risk management,
automating a lot of our
risk and cyber controls,
all of these, we see the same parallel
as we deploy agentic coding
tools at the company,
that they're actually
supercharging our ability
to deploy these tools to our,
you know, 14,000
developers at the company.
So the challenge is that bringing LLMs
into any regulated enterprise
environment creates
a lot of inherent risks.
And, you know, if you don't
address the inherent risks,
like you will spend a lot
of time creating, you know,
a lot of like meetings,
documents, documenting risk,
or you may have to accept certain risk,
which are not always ideal.
At the same time,
when you look at how fast
these agentic coding tools are moving,
you know, how quickly
they're getting better
at a lot of software engineering tasks,
you don't have a lot of time to actually,
you know, get all of these things in shape
to be able to bring these
tools inside the company.
So what we did is that we created
kind of an architecture pattern
that will be a zero trust AI environment
for one of these tools, Claude Code,
but using some of the native
security of AWS Bedrock.
And again, you know, if
you see a common theme
in this whole talk,
is our ability to commingle first party,
you know, third party,
and AWS together to
build a solution quickly.
And I'm gonna skip this slide,
but I'll come directly to this.
And this is an example.
Claude Code is a CLI.
It's a little tool that you
download on your laptop.
And then it needs to have access
to either Anthropic Claude.ai,
you know, they are hosting platform,
or access to Claude through
Bedrock or some other provider.
For us, the Bedrock choice was ideal
because we are using the
account-level permissions
and the Bedrock gateway
as a, you know, enhanced security for us.
We don't have to worry about, for example,
whether, you know, the data
that we are sending there would
be used for training or not.
There are a lot of reasons
why you want to, you know,
use something like Bedrock.
For us, it's the time to market,
the security implications,
and the scale of bedrock and accessing,
you know, Claude Sonnet
and Opus, et cetera,
through the Bedrock ecosystem.
Now, what we have to build
ourselves is the AI gateway.
That's where we focused on,
because that's where we put our controls.
We put, for example, token rate limiting.
You know, you don't want somebody to go in
and, you know, kind of like
spend $1 million worth of tokens
in a single, you know, offline task
because, you know, Claude Code is not same
as like Cursor or Windsurf,
where, it doesn't need an ID, right?
You can write a bad job
and you can say like,
"Go through these 20 depos
and then do some tasks,
you know, do a code review
or fix a bunch of things
and come back,"
and you accidentally give it
like a huge amount of context,
and then, you know, you
get a large token usage.
So we have implemented a
bunch of things, controls,
on our AI gateway.
And we also built in a
lot of like observability
into the gateway
so that we are doing a
lot of detective control
on the traffic itself.
The other thing we have,
we are still learning.
When you let an agent sit on your desktop,
like developer desktop,
it has access to a lot of your files
and a lot of other information.
So you have to create the
right sandbox around it.
But we don't want users
to disable those settings.
So we have a combination
of like managed settings
that we fix from the enterprise side.
And then it also allows, you know,
the developer to set certain
settings on their own.
Again, a lot of that infrastructure,
we had to build ourselves.
But overall, you know, we were
able to bring this to market
to live very quickly in
matter of weeks actually.
So where does it lead us?
This is kind of like forward-looking.
I think our focus on vertically
integrated end-to-end stack
will position us really well
as new technologies come,
new models come,
new architectures come up
in the research community.
Our conscious decision
of intentionally choosing a
combination of open source, AWS,
and third-party solutions,
that has, you know,
worked out really well.
And we think that it'll also
continue to work well for us.
But we are here today because
we spent a lot of time
on designing our infrastructure in a way,
our control plane in a way
that allows us to be able
to get these things from different places
and to build kind of a hybrid platform.
We have full control
over our infrastructure.
We don't depend on any particular,
you know, vendor, et cetera.
We can tune our stack
very well at every level.
And this idea of, you
know, having custom models,
to custom hardware, to custom pipeline,
to custom inferencing stack,
or even if you take it
to the agentic layer,
that is, you know, where I think
a lot of the leverage will come from.
And then the way we are
approaching our risk
and cyber controls by automating them,
by creating, you know,
specialized environments
where these agents can play, so to speak.
And then we are extending these
to all of the other capabilities,
you know, that need AI,
some kind of agent.
For example, in our data platforms,
when our data platforms build data agents,
they're not gonna build a custom,
you know, data agentic platform.
They will start to leverage
our own agent platform, for example.
So we are extending the same
control, same infrastructure.
Everywhere, there is,
you know, a need for AI
or infusing AI into that
particular platform.
Now, key to this is our
ability to attract talent
and develop them.
I think if there is a single,
you know, a differentiator
among companies going forward,
it's really gonna be the talent.
We have been really lucky,
fortunate enough to have
the kind of the ecosystem
and the environment and the culture,
to be able, to be in a position
where we can, you know,
attract a lot of great talent.
And one of the, kind of like
the validations of that,
I mentioned in Evident AI,
three years in a row, we have
been number one in AI Talent,
but we are not stopping there.
In the last couple of years,
we have really started to look across
and forming partnerships
with some of the most
forward-thinking leading universities
in the US.
We have established research
centers at USC, Columbia,
University of Illinois,
University of Maryland,
and more recently, maybe around summer,
we were the only bank and one
of the two companies in the US
that became partner to NSF AI Institutes.
NSF is awarding, I think,
five academic groups,
five national, you know, science
foundation AI institutes.
We partnered with one of them.
And we are the only bank there.
And I personally see some
of the benefits we have had.
You know, we have brought
in a lot of faculty,
a lot of summer interns.
We just started a AI
engineering internship program
starting, you know, from next summer.
These are our pipelines.
And they come in.
They get to work on
world-class infrastructure.
They get to work with world-class
scientists and engineers.
And then, you know, they
are able to actually deploy
something that has tangible value
that actually goes in
front of our customers.
So it's a great flywheel
that we are creating in terms of talent.
So I will end here saying it's
an incredibly exciting time
for us in the AI community and
particularly at Capital One.
You know, as I said, I have worked at,
you know, tech companies.
But I just find Capital One
to be such a amazing place
to allow us to think big
and then to be able to build
this kind of infrastructure at scale.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)